supongamos que esta de aquí es la
gráfica de efe minúscula de x es la
gráfica de efe minúscula de x y digamos
que también tenemos una función f
mayúscula de x para la cual su derivada
f mayúscula prima de x es igual a efe
minúscula de x es igual a efe minúscula
de x dado eso cuál de estas pudiera ser
f mayúscula de x cuál de estas pudiera
ser f mayúscula de x te invito a que le
pongas pausa el vídeo e intentes
encontrar la solución por tu cuenta
bien si esta curva es la derivada de
alguna de estas significa que para todos
los valores de x esta curva representa
la tasa instantánea de cambio o la
pendiente de la recta tangente a la
curva de aquella de estas que
corresponda a efe mayúscula de x veamos
algunas cosas aquí que conocemos de efe
minúscula de x que es la derivada de
alguna de estas aquí vemos que efe
minúscula de x siempre es positiva tiene
un asiento está en cero cuando x tiende
a menos infinito pero efe minúscula de x
siempre es positiva y dado que fx
representa la pendiente de alguna de
estas eso quiere decir que la pendiente
de la función que estamos buscando tiene
que ser siempre positiva y que es lo que
vemos en estas gráficas en esta gráfica
la pendiente de la recta tangente
siempre es positiva
aquí también siempre es positiva a
medida que se incrementa la x se
incrementa la y aquí también siempre la
pendiente es positiva pero aquí no aquí
a medida que aumenta x que disminuye si
es que podemos descartar descartar esta
ahora que otra cosa podemos ver bien
esta es la derivada esto
a la pendiente de la recta tangente así
por ejemplo si x es igual a menos 4 efe
de menos 4 es un valor muy pequeño es un
valor muy cercano a 0 ligeramente mayor
que 0 eso nos dice que la pendiente de
la recta tangente a la gráfica de f
mayúscula de x tiene que ser un valor
cercano a cero cuando x es igual a menos
4 veamos entonces aquí cuando x es igual
a menos 4 la pendiente de la recta
tangente no parece ser cercana a 0 de
hecho parece que es 1
así es que descartamos esta gráfica en
esta de aquí cuando x es igual a menos 4
la pendiente la recta tangente si parece
tener un valor cercano a 0 y en la
última gráfica también cuando x es igual
a menos 4 la pendiente de la recta
tangente también parece tener un valor
cercano a 0 así es que ahora sólo
tenemos que decidir entre estas dos
veamos como podemos elegir la adecuada
pensemos en otro punto cuando x cuando x
es igual a 0 fx
a cerca de uno fx está cerca de uno no
de hecho
fx es igual a uno si fx es igual a uno
así es que para f mayúscula de cero la
pendiente de la recta tangente tiene que
ser igual a 1 veamos las gráficas aquí
la pendiente de la recta tangente parece
muchísimo menor que 1 es muy pequeña no
llega ni a punto 5 en cambio aquí la
pendiente de la recta tangente cuando x
es igual a 0
si parece ser uno la pendiente de la
recta tangente cuando x igual a 0 en
esta gráfica si parece ser uno así es
que esta de aquí resulta ser la mejor
opción para f mayúscula de x ésta es
entonces
efe mayúscula de x y puedes darte cuenta
que se ven muy parecidas de hecho se ven
iguales con lo cual podría recordar de
lo que ya aprendiste cálculo diferencial
que ésta se ve como la función
exponencial natural y aunque no nos
pidieron que
a la función solo nos pidió que
determinaremos cuál podría ser la
gráfica de la anti derivada de esta
función
efe minúscula de x es la derivada de f
mayúscula de x o f mayúscula de x es la
anti derivada de efe minúscula de x y
nos hemos dado cuenta visualmente de que
esta función de hecho ambas funciones
corresponden a a la x pues la derivada
de a la x es a la x